oh this isn't politics well i mean guess
kind of is but it's not this is i saw
you
do you want it you want to set this one
up just made me so mad the
second i saw this i had to send it in
for prep so you wanna you wanna set it
up
so two prank chicks that work for vice
had uh jake paul on after his big fight
against
the boxer the world famous championship
box
jake paul yeah um and they asked him
about his they were talking about his
match with nate robinson and uh they
asked him some stuff
he knocked that guy out i mean he put
him to sleep
i mean he put him down a couple of times
too
but yeah this was uh th this was uh
oh boy is this gonna make people angry i
know what you're about to say
you sided with paul on this one didn't
you
i have sided with jake paul twice in the
last two weeks
and look 2020 has been
weird enough it's been weird enough
i don't need you [ __ ] making me
round out the year 2020 by having to
support jake paul
but god damn it i guess it's just we're
just living in bizarro world now well
let's see what they asked him
oh great thanks twitter twitter video so
i have [ __ ] twitter stinks
refresh it um
i almost started to protest this show
because why
i'll tell you why and this is our
question of the week we saw what
happened to nate robinson so i'm going
to ask jake paul
right here in front of america jake
considering where we are right now in
our racial conversation in america
was what you did to nate robinson racist
why was fighting in a boxing match
against another opponent who was getting
paid was that racist
this is i want you guys to understand
jake paul did not knock out nate
robinson
at vidcon or at a mall you know what i
mean
and they call him a racial slur yeah
it's not like there's a video going
around at jake paul
hitting a black guy with a brick and
calling him the n-word and being like
hey jake dude
you kind of canceled it he literally was
in a boxing match
but this is how and by the way hey hey
far left people
you're you're reaching the end i want
you to know this that you're in your
death rattle
because you won the white house right
and you you've been
you've been over saturating the media
with your [ __ ]
and you're pushing people now you're
pushing normies
you're pushing a political people you're
pushing people that aren't into the
culture war [ __ ]
you're pushing them further and further
away from you
people don't like this people are start
dude i saw a lot of people on twitter
people that are not right wing
that we're going what is this dumb
saying
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you i
am telling you
and i'm warning you on the left if
you're part of this
intersectional uh uh what's the uh
critical race relation um lgbt extreme
left [ __ ]
people's patience is running out and
people are getting really sick of your
[ __ ]
right here in front of america jake
um considering where we are right now in
our racial conversation in america
was what you did to nate robinson racist
that is the question of the week bad
nah stop playing with me come on
listen jake it's a sensitive time right
now we just
had to witness a white man just knock a
black man smooth out in front of all of
america
so that's why i asked that but just just
is she joking
she's trying to choke she's trying to
play it off like
i was playing but like like martina
martinez but no she
means it she wanted to get she needed to
get she got exactly what she wanted she
got this dumb viral clip of course but i
don't think it's going the way she'd
planned
tell us about that that moment real
quick because
this gets better okay was asleep before
he ever even hit the canvas
yeah i mean this is what we train for
you know at the end of the day boxing's
a sport
and uh you know you train to win and
that's that's what i went in there and
did and i
i uh i worked hard for this and you know
nate nate is the one who called me out
originally so
i think he is frozen hey can you hear me
now yeah i can hear you guys now sorry
my wi-fi is unstable like my
relationship
[Laughter]
[Music]
when you do when you do um television or
i mean i know this is not quite
television but it's still it's a
right media outlet you're using your
wi-fi bro
yeah connect dude i would never do that
i wouldn't even do a podcast that's
bigger than mine
unless i made sure like ethernet's
hooked up right especially when you do
like ethernet hooked up
also make sure that your wi-fi isn't
still accidentally open
and you're you know what i mean like
there's things you do to make sure look
when we go live
we we had that with uh infowars anytime
we've been on infowars they don't
[ __ ] play around
they're like make sure you're here
there's a countdown thing right on the
thing
be ready don't be [ __ ] around i'll be
eating on the mic make sure your
internet's good
you just gotta do that but get ready it
gets better
unstable like my relationship
[Laughter]
okay so let's start from the beginning
okay first and foremost
was it racist to knock a black man out
so wait a second they already did the
double down they did the joke all right
okay now it's no joke i'll let it i'll
let
i'll i'll play devil's advocate let's
say the first half was that was a joke
but now the other host is also asking
it's like this watch ready hey royce do
you uh
you like to go to bars and suck dicks no
i was just [ __ ]
just playing ah
hey but no now we're serious do you like
to go no
[Laughter]
so let's start from the beginning okay
first and foremost
was it racist to knock a black man out
that is the question of that oh stop
asking me that i said
no it's not racist it's a shitty
question it's a sport
why is it a shitty question why is it a
shitty question because
how does this have anything to do with
race it just it doesn't
it's a fine question we got to wake you
up you got to be a part of this
conversation that's right
like because if you can go from oh this
is why people hate you
this is why people hate you this is why
people
hate you why is it a shitty question
it's a shitty question
all around we need to wake you up and
get you in this conversation like
this is why people hate you this is why
people hate you
now do you see why i'm like how do i not
support jake paul
it was boxing sometimes white people
fight black people and by the way
there's a lot more videos of black guys
knocking out white guys is that racist
yeah if if let me tell you something if
the sport of boxing is a race war
we're losing yeah we're basketball
football yeah was it racist when mike
tyson knocked peter mcneely and his
entire career off the face of the earth
that's why mike's a big hockey match guy
the only place you're winning guys um
vice ladies and gentlemen that that
this this needs to stop man
this this needs to stop people need to
stop tolerating this